before we say goodbye we want to play a
quick round off truth or dare
we have michael alouacoon hello michael
hi
oh you're so handsome right all right is
it going to be a truth or a dare i think
a truth uh i just have a quick throwback
question if you guys had to give each
other yearbook superlatives what would
they be oh
oh that's that's so unique i love this
question michael huh
all right uh what would you give me i
mean definitely class punter
thank you for that
i would give you uh most likely to date
a gay guy
do you know how many gay guys i have
been in love with yes i do i mean my and
do you know what's so amazing i've been
so gay adjacent my entire life and my
gaydar sucks
i never know when someone's gay oh honey
well if you need to know i am but i'll
tell you
the truth though if i was going to give
you one it would be most likely to
succeed
always count on drew barrymore
and yours would be biggest heart
michael
what do you think your high school
superlative would be if you may see
yourself objectively uh i actually did
get one in high school it was uh most
likely to cure cancer
i mostly do puppet voices for children
now
that's a cure that it's step one
so people thought that you were most
likely to like heal uh mostly i had good
grades yeah
can i just ask could you do a puppet
voice first real quickly this is mr
monkey
and this is mr lyon okay
i love them we love you michael thank
you so much for your
really cool thoughtful question all
right thank you everybody for choosing
to spend your time with us we make this
show for you so
take it with you
[Music]